foreign
what do you guys think happened when you
die on a commercial flight unless you
know I think they they throw you out the
back yeah oh you're at the back like
when you die like Mr spocks
someone died on the flight here what
yeah so like you know how you know how
they did do those things of like if
there's a medical professional please go
to aisle whatever that's for doctors
yeah so
um yeah they did that thing whatever
whatever and then um
I went the bathroom was kind of like
busy so I went to the one to the very
back right where the whole [__] went
down so when I went back there
there were two people like like this
with the whole blanket from top to
bottom just the whole two people by two
laying down I don't know they're just
covered and I don't know if they got
[__] both sick or what I don't know
what the [__] happened
yeah but it looked like a body bag thing
they're laying down no they're no
they're sitting they're sitting you just
imagine sitting next to someone there's
two [__] side by side and they just
have a blanket like covered dude yeah
you wanna know something crazy
that is exactly what they do when a
person dies for real so was there like a
double death or some [__] I don't know
no because people look just like weirded
out right so I went to the bathroom and
then I went back and then I really think
that could have they could have died
because yeah that's the exactly they
said that that [__] the medic had to
come in and all that stuff
the thing that happens is that they
don't tell the plane they try to make it
very very quiet and they just cover them
that's exactly isn't that the worst way
to do it it could have been one but my
mind is thinking too
because they just throw these on yeah
they just put some headphones on them
that's way better
like weekend at Bernie style you know
yeah I feel like the the blanket over
the head is I could be tricking my own
mind and thinking that it was like
multiple people but it could just be one
so usually
um that's that's the most frequent thing
but um if they can they might sit the
body down uh best case scenario like
Singapore Airlines has this can you
imagine sitting next to a dead
[__] well yeah that's it you're
trying to enjoy your [__] everything
everywhere all at once yeah some people
have had to some people had to sit next
to a deadline but the main things that
like best case scenario Singapore
Airlines has this compartment where they
can put the dead body but like no other
airlines has that oh can you imagine
well they got long flights imagine some
guy dies and then they put the sheet
over him but then he's in the aisle seat
and you're [__] the military I gotta
use the John oh my god dude excuse me
excuse me I had to get up so also
they're um and then there's also a
chance that they might be able to sit
the body where the uh uh what is it the
attendant sits oh my God the backpack
they'll just like close the curtain but
most of the time it's exactly what you
described yeah it is where they just
kind of leave them in the seat they put
the sheet over them and they just have
to get on with the flight and once they
get there here's the crazy thing it's
actually
on paper it's impossible to die in a
plane because there's nobody there that
can legally declare you dead
um so technical actually dead
but then you're you're actually great
but not like dead on paper yeah that's
why that's kind of like the whole in a
way loophole like it's not technically a
dead body because there's nobody there
to declare I mean but a dead body is a
dead body what about the deadhead seat
that I saw from Kiss Me If You Can why
can't they sit up in in the front with
the captain with the pilot yep so if
someone dies do I get an automatic first
class upgrade on my next flight they
what they try to do is if there's ways
that they can reseat
um passengers they try to quietly
relocate them to be like hey like if
it's okay and they'll give you a snack
box with it it was a packed flight
though but it was like an apple it was
so weird yeah it was like a blanket like
a pinkish blanket like just covering the
whole thing and it and it looked like a
mummified
you saw a dead person yeah that's a dead
guy why would they cover that's just an
orange guy yeah now I was just walking
by and I was like looking at it like
well you know some people they sleep
like that yeah but like they just cover
their face I do that yeah not like head
to toe because I see people with a
hoodie and then they [__] tie that
like Kenny style and then they go down
but you really wouldn't see that after a
bunch of like people have tried to give
medical exam like a furniture blanket
over the kitchen yeah it could be one of
those things where my mind is just not
just registering until later like yeah
that's probably what happened yeah it
probably you got a [__] U-Haul
blanket it says 8.99 in town all over it
it's like
nobody sits up like this dude nobody
that's right and his seat's not reclined
get out of here that's how you tell what
if there's turbulence
oh
his head's on your shoulders
[__] dude I just want to watch Elvis and
peace like get the [__] out of here kid
I can't imagine though like you know how
sometimes when you die you void your
bowels yeah dude I was thinking the same
thing like don't you doesn't that smell
insane like how do you
yeah what do you what did they say also
like how long is the flight and when did
you die I've given during the time of
the flight what if you died on takeoff
and it's an 18-hour flight oh come on
that's why Singapore Air got the
compartment probably that's crazy
yeah well the lucky thing is if it were
to happen when the plane was still
grounded in some way they can at least
like stop but they don't normally it
says they don't normally like let's say
they're in Flight right yeah they're not
gonna interrupt you can like land here
and just let the body up they don't do
that at all what if that's a hack to to
get the body at the destination what's
it if it's what if it's like a little
hack like a little travel hack like die
on the way to your [__] destination
so then say that's where you're from
right say I'm from Singapore and I'm one
I want to be buried in Singapore
well what if you're visiting Singapore
and now your family's in America and the
boss that's what I mean you got to ship
your body to where you're gonna go dude
my family will take the deal
my family takes the deal you save money
they bury him there yeah he's already
there bury him there yeah bury him
put him in ashes send him back what's
cheaper you know there's another time
that a guy almost died next to me
yeah dude death follows he's going to uh
Las Vegas and then it was funny it was
old dude dressing like Steve dude like
jumpsuit all blinged out like is that
funny what's funny about that it's my
identity
it was him in his it was cute because
they're an old couple
um and matching jumpsuits kind of stuff
you know [__] loud as [__] they're
probably like super big party goers in
the 70s or whatever
and then we're on the we're on the plane
they're sitting next to me they're cool
and then like
he was just kind of um like like
apologetic about something like oh I'm
gonna nap this and oh I didn't sleep
much or whatever right and I was like
okay
and then um wife was sitting next to me
she was really nice and then we take off
and then like you know it's a quick
flight but
um we're about to land like it's a you
know how they tell you like put your
seat belts on whatever uh everything is
kind of like don't get up right so right
when we're about to land she's like
honey are you okay okay she goes honey
honey talk to me talk to me right and
then so he's not answering she goes are
you having a seizure are you having a
seat she's like freaking out she goes oh
what do I do and I'm just like oh [__]
so then I start hitting the the the the
help me button right turn the fan off
and then the lady's looking at me and
she goes oh we can't get up right now
and I'm all like no Spirit I'm like hey
you need to pay first
she's like oh we can't stand up right
now and I'm like it's an emergency he
needs help right so then she's like oh
[__] so they run up and then she's like
uh is he okay like what is the medical
condition she goes oh he's having a
seizure she runs back [__] says is
there any medical professional please
come over people just start [__]
rushing like three people a doctor a
nurse whatever they started like working
over me and [__] so I'm just like let me
[__] get the hell out of the way yeah
and I'm just standing here just on the
other seat like watching and then they
were like what just balls what's this
thing and the whole thing was like
rocking and whatever and we were Landing
like all that [__] was happening right
when they were like oh yeah dude because
it started happening when they they were
doing the whole descending thing we're
gonna land now yeah
how many people uh do you think that
happened to this year who knows dude but
he did he was alive like he they they
made it they found I think they got an
oxygen tank for sure all this [__] and
then as soon as um he was an oxygen oh
okay like they had some [__] and then he
got back up and then the first thing he
said was sorry everyone and then
everyone was like clapping and they're
like don't even worry about it man
[Laughter]
it's gonna delay my entry to the gate
yeah it said that it's first dibs out
what the [__]
2019 I don't know how it is every year
but in 2019 uh a hundred people
how many flights per day there is like
there's a lot too bad it's not the
people who stand up as soon as we land
yeah those people that want to rush
immediately when we land whoa what do
you like what are you what's your
favorite gosh where are you going why
are you [__] Russian in front of me
like she doesn't exist one row at a time
dude yeah that's stupid uh if there was
a God who would strike them all dead but
I don't know I just don't get it like
we're all in this [__] Sardine Can
together like why do you get to rush out
right
unless you you got you know you're late
and then there's like you got a
connection or some [__] you guys some
people have anxiety okay
well [__] that that is cool guess what
guess we also have anxiety the boys in
WW2
and then what could they do about it
what could they do about it Urban
Normandy Beach I gotta turn in a [__]
hamburger meat on the beach dude
well that's why they get to ride first
flight though they hit the board first
okay
that's why they get priority morning
you got anxiety and then you wash your
butt next to you get turned into
hamburger meat and then you're like holy
[__]
there's no like hey time out I don't
want to talk to a counselor crazy
holding out of anxiety I can't run up
sorry I hate hi hello I have anxiety
will anyone
[Music]